hi I'm Graham Luke here from YouTube API
developer relations team if you have no
s developer and you are trying to find
the best way to start integrating
YouTube API into your app we have a
great news for you guys we open source
YouTube direct Lite for iOS recently and
this project the most raise the best
practices for using the YouTube API is
inside your app such as using the
YouTube data API YouTube data API upload
as well as iframe embedded player and
YouTube direct Lite is actually a
platform itself for that so that people
can solicit for videos from their users
so that their users can submit videos to
their playlist so that they can moderate
and choose which videos to show up in
that playlist and for that inside that
people can your users can actually use
this app so that they can record any
video or they can pick any video that
they recorded earlier and upload to
YouTube and submit to your your playlist
as well as they can pick any video they
already uploaded to YouTube before and
that still submit to your playlist and
let's go to my screen and actually see
here from here so the project saw
standard get up is on the github comm
slash YouTube YouTube direct Lite iOS
and in this project we are using the
objective-c client libraries for Google
API s so that it handles the
totalization and it makes it really easy
to talk with the good YouTube data API
let's go to project itself and see the
project from there here actually starts
with the authorization door too and we
are given the transition
and we are login to my account and we
are exposing this app choose my account
now actually I can't
the app is going through and it's
actually going through my playlist I
applause playlist and pulling to all the
playlist items from there and through
the videos list code it's actually goes
like for all these videos
it picks brings up the videos titles the
view count as well as the video duration
and you know for bringing you to ton the
thumbnails as well so if you if you
click any of the videos here we are
actually anything the YouTube iframe
embed player and here actually fusing
the episode streamer if you are like
want to go for the full screen that's
one option or from the iframe embed
playing of options you can actually set
plays in line one so that actually put
the player actually will play the video
inside the application so after seeing
like any video we can submit it to a
playlist or we can actually record a
completely video with the camera or we
can actually pull one of the videos I
have in my already saved in my eye is
device and from there I can actually
even play the video before sake thing
and if I'm sure I want upload this video
we just playing
I can set like a new title and I can
start the video right now we are using
the YouTube data API resumable uploads
so the upload is like going on the
background as well and once we the
upload is finished actually book source
is ID the video ID that's already
uploaded and see actual video is
uploaded we get videos ID and actually
this video besides uploading to my
account interests is submitted to the
playlist that I want to submit for and
here was like the
direct light for is so in this project
we demonstrated the YouTube data API
such as we should pull from the youth
users playlist we use the iframe embed
player so that we will be able to play
those users like you look videos as well
as we use the data API uploads the
resumable upload so that we were able to
upload videos to YouTube and you can use
this project to start your application
yeah instead of like starting from
scratch as well as we can go here to see
to find the best examples as well thanks
for listening today and Ibrahima here
from YouTube